it's very timely that we approve this
strategic compass
in a moment in which i think every
citizens in europe can understand
the purpose of a document who wants to
increase and strength
european union as a security
provider
as i said this is the result of two
years of hard work
and i want to thank
my team at the external action service
and also all ministers of defence
and foreign affairs that has been
working on that
for all this time even this weekend a
lot of last minute work
in order to ensure that everybody was on
board
you have been heard me talking about
quite a long
many times during this long period of uh
two years
and i want just to stress the fact
that is not
an answer to the latest international
development in particular to the russian
military aggression in ukraine
it's uh
an answer to the feeling that european
union has to be
more engaged coordinating the efforts of
the member states
in order to increase the capacity of all
of us together
certainly in complementarity with nato
in order to make europe more stronger
i presented the start of the
compass
the draft that we presented to the
members stage in november
i said europe is in danger and this
sentence
well many believe that it was a matter
of
selling the product
to attract attention of the people to
give a headline
well today i think everybody is
convinced
that europe is in danger
that is blatantly obvious
due to the
invasion of ukraine it's not
arithmetic
but the contrary this invasion and the
war that is going on
is a tectonic shift
on the geopolitical landscape of europe
and our reaction
to the war has demonstrated that we as
the european union we can actually unite
it
and today that
purpose confirms this capacity
will help us
to stop
to act
to act
in response to crisis
to secure our union and our
european citizens
increase our resilience
to invest
in the required capabilities
and in defence innovation
it's important to know how much
europeans
are spending on their defense and to
follow the evolution of the military
expenditure
since the beginning of the century
passing by the crimean action in 2014
until this moment
these figures are important in order to
understand where we are where we are
coming from
and why we should react
today the military expenditure in europe
of all member states adding up
it's about 200 000 million euros
of the gmp
it was decreasing until 2014
decreasing quite quickly
and since 2000
started increasing again
until 1.5
but
we have to invest more
everybody will understand that we want
to push
and to be more able to face situations
probabilities
and with 1.5 the gmp is not enough
we have to spend more people these
defense gaps where are the polls in
which we don't have the means and ways
to react
what we are missing
and what we are having two or three
times in a duplication that is not
effective
this 200 000 million euros
is more or less
four times the military spending of
russia
altogether we spend almost four times
russia
but certainly not with same efficiency
two hundred thousand million euros in
the same military spending of china
altogether we spend as much as china
but certainly
it's not the same thing 27 different
parts
that one integrated military structure
we don't want to create an european army
it's not about creating a european army
the european armed miss
will remain each member state having its
own
military army
but we have to work together closer
we have to coordinate better our
expenditure
we have to be able to react
and one of the ways to react rapidly is
this rapid deployment capacity
that has been agreed i am very happy
that finally this proposal has been
agreed by the member states
which will allow us to mobilize 5000
troops
train and equip to react to crisis
we will strengthen our
control and command capabilities
we'll conduct
life exercises together it has never
been happening never
european armies has been training
together apart from the nato framework
and we will better tools to fight hybrid
attacks hybrid campaigns
cyber threats and foreign interference
and manipulation of information
because the battlefields of tomorrow
are also on the networks are in the
cyberspace are in the outer space on the
high sea
it's not only a matter of conquering
land it's conquering minds of the people
and the minds of the people at the end
determines the behavior of their
governments
and the votes for example on the united
nations
so there is a big work to do
not with guns but with words with ideas
countering
propaganda and
this information and present things the
way they are
this will allow us to support our
partners
and to be a better partner
to support our partners that we are
doing now with ukraine
and to be a better partner
a better partner inside european
inside the nato
with the united nations
and with the african union
we cannot act alone we want to act in a
more coordinated way among us
and we want to act in a more integrated
way with our partners
acting in complementarity with nato
which remains certainly
the the cornerstone of the territorial
defense of europe
but
we europeans with this document
we stated
our strong will
to be
a stronger security provider for our
citizens for the stability of the world
and for the peace of the world
we will be more effective on facing
crisis securing acting investing and
partnership
this is not a document to keep in the
shelf
this is a guide to action
with a concrete timeline
that's what we have to do and when we
have to do
this has to be
updated
frequently
it has been updated in the last weeks in
order to
stress the importance of the ukrainian
wall
not because uh we didn't
we didn't discover
before the ukrainian war that russia was
one of the most important challenges
that we are facing we knew it
we knew it and it was considered since
the beginning in our threat analysis
but it was much more evident
and we have to adapt the text in order
to reflect the current situation but it
will have to be updated
often
we have to be
under the control of the leaders of the
european union council to which i
present i will present
the compass
on the next meeting
this week
now finally finally let me say one thing
this is only the beginning
this is only the beginning
we are going to work a lot on that it's
time to translate
all these purposes into concrete results
we need to study our defense gaps
we need to fill these defense gaps
we need to be effective coordinated
we have to increase our resilience
and certainly we will have to ask for a
better commitment of the european
citizens as taxpayers
in order to make the european union
as i said at the beginning a better
security provider
otherwise
otherwise we will be in danger
we are in danger
and in order to face these dangers we
have to
take consciences
full conscience of that and act
accordingly with that i think that
the ukrainian war has been
a kind of uh awakening
for our conscience
for example the
energy dependency is something that
we have been increasing by energy
dependency from russia for years
and now we take full conscience
of the weaponization of dependencies
dependency become a weapon
it is a weapon
that is being used as a weapon
and we have to react
with someone using something as a weapon
against us
we are not a military union we are not a
military alliance
but we want to play a role in order to
provide to the european citizens more
security
in a challenging and dangerous world
we are not living in the world we would
like to be
we live in the world the way it is
and this world is dangerous this world
is challenging
our neighborhood is in flames from
gibraltar to ukraine we are surrounded
by a circle
of challenges
of dangerous situation
and we have to face them
and that's why
we have been working with all member
states
to produce these analysis this approach
of fulfilling the mandate of the treaty
of the union
who clearly states that the union has to
build progressively
a common security and defense policy
charging the high representative
to conduct this work
and it's my pleasure
to present to you after two years of
work
what is certainly a big step forward
to the building of this common and
security policy for the european union
thank you
i forgot that we had a fact this morning
certainly we had a fact this morning and
in the effect this morning uh
we did a lot of things apart from the
strategic compass the teja compass was
uh
on the way because my team was
trying to arrange the last
the last things that could allow us to
have him on board
all member states
but before the jumbo meeting with the
defense ministers
we had
another important meeting with the
foreign affairs ministers
and as you can imagine the invasion of
ukraine by russia
was the main issue in agenda
the ministers analyzed the situation
and decided to continue
and
taking decisions today was not the
moment to take concrete decisions
but to have a look at where we are and
what is going to happen and what can we
do on the next days
the conclusions are very clear
all member states remain
extraordinarily united in
supporting ukraine
supporting ukraine diplomatically and
international stage
we will continue isolating russia
to call out
for war crimes
for blatant violations of humanitarian
and international law
we will continue supporting ukraine
economically
financially
with humanitarian assistance
and supporting ukrainian armed forces
i am glad to announce
that we have reached a political
agreement
for the additional 500 millions under
the european peace facility
and we considered that what's happening
in ukraine
is a
a war crime a massive war crime
committed by the russian armed forces
against ukrainian people
and this cannot go and answer it
and that's why
we welcome the commission of inquire set
up by the united nations human rights
council
we welcome the investigation by the
international criminal court prosecutor
and we recall the order by this
international court of justice
for russia to stop the invasion of
ukraine
restrictive measures
constitute continue constituting a part
an important part
of our approach and we are ready to take
further
according with our partners
we will continue engaging with
international partners
in order to
continue putting pressure
on russia
at the end of the meeting we were joined
by the deputy prime minister and foreign
minister of moldova
nico popescu
moldova as you know is one of the
countries more affected and most
threatened by the russian aggression
they are responding with an incredible
generosity and solidarity with their
ukrainian neighbors
30 percent of the children in moldova
today
are children from ukraine
refugees from ukraine
and the education system
is under huge strain but they are
integrating them fully
allowing them to continue learning
they need our support
we will provide all the support they
need in order to face
this challenging situation
the ministers
collectively committed
to step up our support to moldova
at that moment there are
3.2 maybe at that hour of the day
maybe 2.
sorry 3.3
million of refuges
and the flow continues
i am convinced that putin is using the
refugees as a as a tool
as an arm
sending as much as they can
they haven't destroyed the transport
infrastructure
they just destroyed the cities
in order to terrify the civilians and
make them escape
we are ready to
help all of them
this is a symmetric burden
because some member states in the buddha
are having
a strong burden they are facing
this flow of refugees in the front line
but all member states will be
in full solidarity
to attend these people
then we talk about mali
the situation in mali is not good
the attitude of the malian authorities
has pushed
barakan and the special forces
of the takuba
to live
atrocities
activities
[Music]
uh
foreign
authorities if we don't get them
requested
now
what the decision
[Music]
well
increase in prices
[Laughter]
you have the floor
just up here um i want to ask about the
discussion on um an energy import ban
from from russia is there any
frustration in germany's resistance
is there any frustration
does this work can you hear me now we
can hear you okay but please
i won't hear you i'll repeat
um i wanted to ask about the discussion
about uh
possible energy import ban on russia is
there any frustration on
germany's resistance to such an import
ban
and with biden's visit later this week
could the u.s help alleviate any
economic pain that such an import ban
would have
on european countries thank you
see i'm going to speak in spanish
because i already speak in english and
french let's use spanish also
see
much
[Music]
today was
is
foreign
thank you now i will go to the
colleagues remotely
and i will give the floor to christian
we move from hello
we were talking
[Music]
publicly
uh uh providing arms but not delivering
it
we didn't entirely understand that third
question you say and what did you
remember
yes this morning on upon arrival
the
is
uh
europeans
for themselves
at the european level
and we've tried
[Music]
of course it's not going to happen
overnight
committed
no document
in reality
resources
you have the floor
no you have to go to the
yes
and please present yourself on your
media
james bay is from al jazeera high
representative you say no concrete
decisions today
you've got a very busy week of diplomacy
ahead do you expect there to be further
sanctions adopted this week and could
they be extended to the energy sector
and also there are reports that russia
may want sanctions lifted as part of any
peace deal so are your eu sanctions
permanent or are they potentially
negotiable
look
formal adoption of sanctions require
procedure
and i don't think during this week it
will be
a formal adoption of sanctions according
with our procedures
but certainly the european union
council
when we'll
be discussing about the situation in
ukraine
the leaders i'm sure they will consider
again
what
what else can be done on the field of
sanctions
in any case the european union council
provides political guidance
and this political guidance then is
being converted in practical and
concrete decisions legally binding by
the technical bodies
so i don't think it's going to be a
formal decision of a new package of
sanctions but certainly the european
union council will provide guidance
about how to
to develop the future
and i don't want to speculate about
what is going to be or not on the
[Music]
negotiation for a ceasefire
but i want to insist
on the absolute need of stopping this
war
all the war reaches an end
and they reach an end through an
agreement
and the first step for an agreement is a
ceasefire
keep in mind the sufferances
of the people in mario paul
keep in mind the people who have been
bombed killed
people who are
starving
escaping
the houses of the european are full of
images on their tv screens of what's
happening in ukraine
this has to stop
and on that
on stopping this wall
now we are using all our diplomatic
efforts we are supporting ukraine we are
pushing for negotiations
we ask to russia to stop this barbaric
war
and once the ceasefire will be agreed
then certainly it will have to be
negotiations about
how to make the peace permanent
and sanctions
sanctions
essentially they are a way of putting
pressure
and believe me they are
they are damaging a lot of russian
economy
laura you have the floor
hello
is
and do you think that the eu will be
coming into line with the resolution for
the eu
well i'm sorry
not going to be able to say that much
foreign
that doesn't say anything different if
you don't mind i will take one last
question remotely uh and it will be
rosie
thank you very much um can you hear me
yes but you need to raise your voice
because we can hardly hear you
okay uh rosie burchard for feature story
news high representative could you give
us some more details on uh mali you said
you're asking for security guarantees
from the transitional authorities what
are those and can you flesh out though
you mentioned support to burkina faso
and niger what kind of support is that i
think it was relatively vague until now
what are the plans there thank you very
much
the
military
[Music]
leave certain activities
[Music]
in addition
and citizens
thank you very much and this uh
closes our press conference today uh you
have still a foreign affairs council
but we still have another
another council meeting yes with the
defense ministers the defense ministers
to make the point
on the military situation in ukraine
from the exact the
the military approach where the war is
what's happening in the ground
today with the minister of foreign
affairs we have been discussing about
sanctions diplomacy
uh vote in the united nations
now we are going to study
deeply
how the war is going
and
i think we are going to share
important information about
the military situation in the ground
and they are waiting for you and you're
waiting
thank you very much have a nice evening